the Far Cry series isn't afraid to
switch up locations or introduce
entirely new stories between Games Far
Cry 4 follows this trend but some of the
most interesting changes are the subtle
ways Ubisoft is attempting to marry the
narrative with the gamep
play we tried to glue the narrative and
the open world more tightly together in
Far Cry 4 we didn't want that moment
where the the story is telling you your
budd's being you know tortured in a
basement and you're off Hunting you know
goats uh you know that cognitive
dissonance so the the general narrative
is about conquering space and taking
back space and even the open world
activities if you break them down are
also about taking back space so we tried
to get that uh you know more tightly
bonded which allowed us to have Story
characters responding to you know open
world incidents whereas in previous
games when you cleared an area it was it
was almost empty of incidents except
maybe the odd sort of wild animal this
time around even when you've cleared an
area there'll be uh guys retaliation
parties coming through to attack the
local Villages there'll be people trying
to take back the outposts um you'll
still see the odd Skirmish between uh uh
the bad guys and and the local Villages
so hopefully this time it feels a lot
more
alive while other Story characters will
react to you conquering space you're not
going to hear As Much from the player
character AJ my personal tastes are in
especially in a first person game that I
am the lead character and so I pushed it
very much in the direction of Silent
protagonist you know you you react if
it's horrible you with the controller
should be saying oh it's horrible
instead of your character Yan I don't
like the distance that's created when
the character says something that I
disagree with and I think my my fear is
that all the people who liked the lead
in Far Cry 3 will dislike AJ and all the
people who didn't like the lead in far
will like AJ because it's those it is
that flip you know of taste it's a
different approach to it the game isn't
going to judge AJ for his actions he can
swap between working for the game's
faction leaders at will and there's no
reward for sticking with one single
faction leader right to the end in the
narrative where you have to choose
between the two faction leaders there
are actually no rewards at all it's it's
purely meant to be your personal
decision and it's built so you can
flip-flop as many times as you want
until you have to make a final decision
and so it's hopefully a narrative
decision you know or like I'm
comfortable with this person I'm
uncomfortable with what you're asking me
to do and it's not that I need the boot
of speed or the gauntlets of power uh uh
on the other side intellectually I like
it and I'm glad we did it but I think
people are so used to doing tasks in
games for stuff that I'm that I think
there's going to be a percentage of
people who are very angry that they go
all the way through a sequence of
choices and don't get that you know the
the large gold helmet it's not as simple
as picking sides between good or evil
the lack of in-game rewards means that
choice is a personal one but there will
still be subtle consequences in later
missions and even though both factions
have their problemss both also seem to
offer solutions to the Region's
difficulties in our heads it was an
argument between sort of traditionalism
and all of the the cool things and also
dangers that come along with that and
the other side is progressiveness and
the same sort of thing you know so
sometimes you're like oh of course you
should you should do this and then you
know we try to say oh well there are
also these consequences that maybe you
didn't think through and then do you
want to stay with it and for that to
become more intense or do you want to to
go the other way and the thing I think
is that a lot of the consequences
because we just Chang the objectives in
the next mission or we Chang the mission
they're semi invisible so people so I
wonder if people are so used to playing
games where the objectives are the
objectives you know that they're they're
not even going to notice in a in a in a
strange
way these consequences play into how
Ubisoft describes Far Cry 4 as an
anecdote Factory you know every second
is a story but anecdotes are usually
short-lived moments that though cool
don't really have the same impact as a
broader traditional narrative so the
question is how do you transform an
anecdote Factory into a narrative
Factory it's fun to follow along you
with a story but the thing that make
games unique and powerful and really
interesting to me is that your story
being different to mine and being
personal I think it is more powerful so
it may be less custom in how we
celebrate it you know like if I know I
know if you've done something and I've
controlled it I can celebrate in a
really specific way and you can get the
medal at the end of the game from the
characters that you helped and all that
sort of stuff but I think that can still
happen in the emerging narrative and it
can still happen in an anecdote you know
Factory sort of way it's just a lot more
work for us and it's still an unsolved
problem so it's something that I'm
really interested in in tackling that
idea that that the anecdotes aren't just
uh you know one-offs that they aren't
just moments that somehow that they can
Cascade into bigger anecdotes and you
can end up in radically different places
in the narrative but with Ubisoft
doubling down on annualized franch
frises and games that try to appeal to
as broad an audience as possible is it
even the kind of Studio where this kind
of emergent narrative could be built
absolutely and and we sort of have an
ongoing debate within the studio of you
know there's risk and then there's you
know obviously we need to make enough
money to support the studio uh and so if
you want to do something crazy part of
the onus on us as developers is to to
make it you know not super cheap
obviously but cheap enough that we're
not going to syn the ship if we if we
blow it up but uh one of the things I
love about Ubi and that keeps me there
is that they're they're very tolerant of
risk and that they they do you know they
they have a history of launching IPS and
it's exciting you do there is room at
Ubisoft to go in and pick something
crazy and walk out the door with them
saying all right give it a shot which is
not something you get everywhere all of
this adds up to just the beginning of
what could be possible in future game
narratives games where Story characters
react in context to the primary focus of
the main mechanics games that push
player character his personalities to
the background so the player has room to
express their own viewpoints games that
then ask players to actually examine
those viewpoints through choices that
shape the narrative rather than ask them
to pick between item rewards games that
roll one anecdote of emerging gameplay
into the next in a way that creates a
broader consistent player-driven
narrative it may sound ambitious but it
also sounds like Hutchinson's end game
if I could one day do a game where you
felt the same epic narrative as a as a
scripted game but it was all through
activities that you'd perform that you'd
chosen to to pursue then I think you
know that's that's good we can retire
that's it I'm
out